es oficial la Corte Penal Internacional
emitió una orden de arresto contra el
presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin por
cometer supuestos crímenes de guerra
tras la invasión de Ucrania en febrero
de 2022
los jueces han revisado la información y
las pruebas presentadas por el fiscal y
han determinado que existen acusaciones
creíbles contra estas personas por
presuntos crímenes
el organismo emitió la orden contra
Putin y María el boba belova comisaría
para los derechos de la infancia como
sospechosos a por deportación de niños y
traslado forzoso de ucranianos Pero cómo
de probable es que se lleven a cabo
estas detenciones la Corte Penal
Internacional es un organismo que sólo
puede ejercer jurisdicción sobre los
países afirmantes del acuerdo y Rusia no
lo es por eso no tiene poder para
extraditar a los sospechosos algo por lo
que el kremlin señaló esta orden de
detención o como nula
Rusia al igual que varios estados no
reconoce la jurisdicción de este
tribunal y en consecuencia cualquier
decisión de este tipo es nula para la
federación rusa desde el punto de vista
del derecho
no obstante esta decisión sí tiene un
fuerte peso simbólico está pensada para
dañar la imagen de Putin a nivel
internacional y le dificultará viajar
especialmente a los países que están
inscritos a la cpi como Francia o Reino
Unido ya que los miembros están
obligados a restar a cualquier persona
acusada por el tribunal
es una decisión histórica a partir de la
cual comenzará la responsabilidad
histórica el jefe de estado terrorista y
otros funcionarios rusos se han
convertido oficialmente en sospechosos
de crímenes de guerra
mientras Rusia ha querido restar
importancia a la decisión Ucrania y los
países en miembro de las dpi sostienen
que abre una vía para perseguir
responsabilidades pero lo cierto Es que
es muy poco probable que Putin tenga que
sentarse en el banquillo de los acusados
del tribunal
[Música]